you got your start uh as an actor you
started doing summer stock
yes right and is that something a lot of
a lot of actors do you think it's kind
of a throwback i think i'm a bit of a
throat
yeah i um when i was in college every
summer
i would work for free or at a different
theater
a summer stock theater in the country
and you would um just be an apprentice
you'd build the sets and you'd make the
costume and
you know hang the lights and sell the
tickets and and sometimes you'd get to
be on stage so you just did it
to be honest did you live in dormitories
how does that work when you do something
different
different places different things
timberlake playhouse in illinois i lived
in a little
shed behind the theater that i just got
room and board so that wasn't so
right exciting except i also got the
coke machine money at the end of the
summer
because i was the company person and
then
at the barn theater in augusta michigan
i lived with trish and priscilla
buckholz for 35
a week and at the georgia shakespeare
festival i lived in a dorm
it does sound sort of like vaudeville
like the old days yes and what
what kind of person were you when you're
doing this because you seem like you're
such a like you'd be like
you'd do a real good job you'd be
earnest you'd try hard i was i did as a
matter of fact my parents visited me at
the barn theater and
the owner of it came out and told my mom
i had just been on stage in a production
and she told her what a nice job i did
but my mom's proudest moment was she
said
that i was the best bathroom cleaner
they'd ever had
so she didn't care how you were in king
lear that didn't matter
but at that place it was weird i went
through a weird i didn't
drink i was never a big party girl but i
um i streaked you streaked
yeah you streaked you took off all your
clothes and wrapped why
but i mean i had were you on medication
i mean what
no i just was in a naked frame of mind
okay
yeah we i just i don't think i was the
only streaker but i might have been the
leader of the streakers
and we just all streaked all summer
after the show late at night i mean i
don't know i don't even know why we're
talking about this but i did i did it i
did it
i think you've wanted to get this out
for a long time and i think you felt
like this was a safe environment yeah
definitely
don't tell my parents no you would take
off your clothes and streak that's
pretty stunning it doesn't seem it
doesn't seem like you at all to just do
that and run around naked
it was i mean it must have been six or
seven years ago yeah it's probably those
buckholtz girls
yeah that's what it was yeah you haven't
doesn't that don't you guys ever i mean
i feel like i've seen
what what are you talking about two of
you two of us what
you don't ever just get the urge to do
what take your clothes off
oh i thought you meant the other thing
uh no
no we never i have never streaked in my
life i've never been naked in my private
life
i was always encouraged to be clothed at
all times andy what about you
i don't i don't mind the nudity but it's
the movement that's the problem
if i'm gonna be naked outside i'm gonna
be pretty stationary it's
probably a better idea yeah yeah yeah
i've seen nandy naked but in a
barcalounger yeah oh yeah
and then he just gets pulled on a rope